Let's revisit our restaurant menus example from the last unit. And we have
objects for representing menus, as well as for representing a dish. So here's
some code we might use to define a dish class. We only have two methods, we've
defined init method which takes name, price, and description and assigns those
to attributes of the self object. And we define the str method. Which turns it
into string and I've used the string format method to do that. Formats are a
really useful method provided by the string built in type provided by thumb. We
can see it's a string method. Here's the string. And then we're using dot and
format as the attribute and we're calling that method, passing in these values.
There are lots of things that we can do in this format string to get output the
way we want. Here the special syntax with the squiggly braces allows us to put
values inside our string and in this case we're putting a value of name which is
what was passed in as the name parameter. So its going to print out the name of
the dish followed by the description with parenthesis around it and now for the
price we've got the price has our value passed in as price and that's a number,
we want that to appear with two decimal points. So it'll all look like this and
that's what we get with a .2f. We could of course have written our own code to
do all this if we didn't know about format but format a really easy way to
generate formatted strings and there are lots and lots of different things we
can do with format. I'm not going to go into details here. I'm going to assume
that you're all enough of a pythonista, at this point, to be able to figure it
out yourself. From the Python documentation, and from examples. And you'll find
a link to that below.